jetzt ein plan soll ich das wollte ich
nicht alles lesen sie jetzt nichts etwas
glaubt netz willkommen bei einem 9
was geht ab herz bekommen wir sind hier
heute in köln
und wir haben uns ich weiß das haben wir
uns nicht ausgedacht ich hab es auf
jeden fall jetzt auch schon öfter in
youtube deutschland gesehen
es kommt natürlich mal wieder aus
amerika wie sollte es auch sonst sein
aber wir haben uns den spaß auch nicht
nehmen lassen und haben uns hier das eco
alex du bist auch einmal in deinem leben
wirklich selber eingeleitet und es ist
nicht deine freundin für dich machen
einmal aus nachbars auf jeden fall ich
hab eingekauft ich habe hier fake sachen
gekauft und originale drachen ja seht
ihr wahrscheinlich wegschubst origin
chips von pringles genau und cola ich
weiß jetzt dass cognis kohle eimer und
nochmal cola und dann hier noch tricks
maß nicht an und so weiter ein originals
und einmal ein fake letzten jahr von der
marken ein konzept ist folgender mal zu
ihren schal es werden natürlich immer
die augen verbunden von dem tester und
ich zum beispiel sucht dann die sache
aus für die moral ein
dann gebe ich halt dem tester die sache
den mund ohne jetzt zweideutig denken zu
müssen und dann muss er halt schmecken
welches besser schmeckt und dann gucken
immer ob das original besser schmeckt
oder der fact finder der kamera ist
gerade auch noch sehr gefährlich der
russe ja und wer sage er testet
natürlich gleich auch so ich würde sagen
ich habe anfragen ist nein will ich mich
was ja sagst du mir weiß noch heute die
hat neulich sagte nicht was kommt ich
anfangen ja hier mit ja zu votieren das
andere offen wer weiß was das problem
ist ich glaube dass andere gibt's ganz
mit dem ich habe ja okay okay das erste
teil kommt ja ist eigentlich sehr lecker
[Musik]
was ist das richtig okay für das andere
ein bisschen mehr
das war das original mindset überlegen
welche zwar leckere ist erstmal das vom
geschmack her doch irgendwas dem
geschmack der kriegs und lecker okay der
gut da bin ich mal sagen hat tricks die
erste runde gewonnen also tricks oracle
lohnt sich anscheinend oder dein
geschmack ist nicht so cool aber ich
würde mal sagen gut gemacht
ok eine sache noch bei ihr okay so ich
würde sagen wir nehmen
okay das merkt man ja sofort mit 6 1
klar
wir checken jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
ob die fake chips genauso lecker sind
wie die original pringles chips
ich würde sagen wir fangen einfach mal
mit den hier an
mal gucken was dieser hass es war nicht
gut
ok dann gucken wir jetzt mal was zu dem
hier sagst du also die erste nicht an
fall also so wie sarah cream geschmeckt
aber die zwar einfach nur richtig noch
salz und durch den premium gespräch
welche waren es besser die ersten auch
richtig krass nicht schlecht vom schlag
ein so viel wie ich es ok und leider
will ich mal sagen was wir weiter mit
sehr gefährlich oder soweit fertig der
russe kennen wahrscheinlich einige von
euch ja war schon öfter mal dabei du
hast ja scheiße kommen
das aussehen so ist gut jetzt machst mir
angst
sorry das wollte ich nicht ausweisen
es kann ja alles okay okay so ich würde
sagen wir fangen jetzt mal hier mit an
ok
so sehr wir selber ein bisschen und 100
sagte ja schmeckt man schmeckt lecker
schmeckt das nach origin oder fake ich
weiß nicht braucht den zweiten dann
gehen wir mal den zweiten stellen
achtung der server kleiner und schmeckt
auch gut ist aber genau das ist ein
fluss als der originale falsch schreibt
dass sobald details du findest dass die
fed nicht mal schlecht besser schmecken
als sanierer wasser vom geschmack her
takt ist es was sind das für eine logik
dass die kleine türke genannt sind weil
wir müssen sparen
aber gucken wir an die politik einer
daraus erst da nicht auch also ich finde
wenn man also nebeneinander hält dann
sehen die schon besser aber die schmeckt
natürlich okay das heißt besser eingehen
und die schmecken besser haben sie
schmeckt natürlich kein würden ja aber
guck mal aber wenn man hier anguckt dann
ist sie sahen sich etwas aus es hier ja
dass der originale nicht aber meine lisa
die tiere besser da ist sie an zu flucht
und sie ist dann zu fest ist doch egal
wer gehört auf jeden fall nicht den
originalen erkannt ok eine sache noch
ich hab mir die idee eine sache und zwei
sachen die mit van gaal
juli ja achtung das mexiko kostet ja was
ist wohl kokos artig mit schokolade und
mein steak oder oracle hat im 2
ich möchte uns dann klein schmecken
total gleich
ich glaube der hat einfach keinen
geschmack steht klappt das erste das
erste original fake und das zweite wagen
genau richtig damit ich jetzt drei leute
jetzt bin ich dran so leute ich bin dran
komme ich bin sogar so gut ich kann mir
das sogar selber umbildung vergleich zu
euch eigentlich müsste ich ja kein nach
einhauen nur damals fällt ja dann auch
keine reinen ein okay okay ich bin
lieber mit van gaal
mit coca-cola kittchen
danke
so testet man halt auch in meinem
berufsfeld den weinanbau so test man hat
dem bald wirst youtuber und keinen wein
einen bautyp kann ich noch ein glas das
mit 120 die originale kohler
nein war das nicht das war nicht
original gib mir mal das andere das
fahrrad gib mir jetzt mal die dein ernst
wenn ich die trinke dann denke ich mir
so das ist so richtig so man erinnert
sich zurück wenn man zu viel cola
gemischt mit wodka getrunken hat weil
die strecken wieder nach kuba schmeckt
auf keinen fall also auf jeden fall
kauft zu 100 prozent coca cola oder
pepsi kann ich da nur sagen
okay okay danke sehr glitschig auf jeden
fall mal sehr gut klappt ist in der
video beschreibung verlinkt ja
eigentlich die zwei sind gleich mit
jetzt weiß nicht gleich jahren christen
gleich ich glaube hier in diesem raum
ist nur eine frau hält man nicht
schlagen nein das war nicht so gemeint
war das zweite runterpflücken
[Musik]
schwenke einfach echt komplett gleich
das ist dass speck und dass der fonds
oder fake und anders das erste war
original fällt ja das erste echte tja
alter die haben nicht komplett gleich
geschmeckt das war jetzt eigentlich so
fasst geraten
wie heftig das schmecken einfach die
gefälschten genauso wie die original ja
heute so viel erstmal dazu wir hoffen
ihr hattet spaß wir hatten auf jeden
fall spaß oder
und ich würde sagen bei 15.000 likes
machen wir das eventuell oder ja ja
abonnieren nicht vergessen checkmate und
instagram war zwischenzeitlich mal ein
gemeiner und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder euch allen einen guten
rutsch ein frohes neues jahr ich wünsche
euch alles liebe vom herzen und ich
glaube ich habe genau gerade 500.000
abonnenten erreicht richtig fresh und
heftig krass und übertrieben dankeschön
dafür 500.000 cast und wir sehen uns
haut rein dazu will noch etwas an was
noch vergessen zu sagen macht euch keine
sorgen die ganzen süßigkeiten werden
natürlich gegessen ich war in
süßigkeiten
wir arbeiten ganz viele menschen da wo
wir das gerade aufnehmen und deswegen
will ich sagen ich geh jetzt einfach
nach oben und verteilt süßigkeiten
wir sehen uns dort rein